فيش اكل حبه هرز الطحين ما فيش يعني انا
اليوم بتت في العياده على شان اجيب
لاولادي رطل طحين جيت لقيت الدور واصل
جهنم وهيني روحت بدون ولا جرام وانا ما
فيش عندي طحين ع ايام طيب لوكش هال
المعناه هذه اليوم احنا نبحث قاعدين عن
بسكوت يومنا من يوم ليوم اليوم القبح
الطحين خلص القمح اليوم كمان في السوق مش
موجود اليوم الناس ت تاكل الذره كلها هذه
بتروح اصلا مش مش اكل للبنادمين هذه كلها
لازم تروح للحيوانات ولطيور اليوم رطل
الطحين حقه 60 شيكل مش موجود انا ه قاعد
بلف اشتري خبز جاهز كمان مش موجود اليوم
كل مواطن فلسطيني في غزه عنده ثمن تنفار
بده معدل من 100 شيكل ل 150 شيكل معيشه
يوميه قلنا الناس ل 110 ايام ما عندها
دداخل شيكل واحد فكيف الناس تعيش الله
يكون مع الناس الوضع صعب جدا جدا
جدا
ه